foreign
[Music]
would probably sound like a nightmare
for most of us am I right
however linguine is just a terrible cook
so he more than welcomes Remy the rat's
extraordinary cooking skills and they
soon build a special friendship fun fact
many of the recipes that we see in this
movie are in fact traditional French
dishes just like the one that we see
Remy cooking here which is in fact
potato and leek soup so much so that the
scene that we've just watched inspired
many popular chefs they actually tried
to recreate this dish like this one that
has over 13 million views so here's what
we're going to do today first off you
are going to watch the scene with
subtitles and see how much you can
understand if you get a little bit lost
no big deal because we are going to
teach you all the most important
vocabulary cultural context connected
speech grammar and more so that finally
in the last part you can test your
English by watching again without
subtitles and you're going to see how
much your comprehension has improved all
right and we don't want you to miss a
single new lesson with your favorite
Disney movies your favorite series and
so much more because every single week
we help you to understand fast speaking
natives without getting lost without
misled jokes and without subtitles so
what are you waiting for hit that
subscribe button and the bell down below
and join our community on millions of
Learners who have found the most fun way
to learn English oh yeah
[Music]
garbage boy
cooking I'm dare you cooking my kitchen
where do you get the phone to even
attempt to fix it so Monumental
torn and quartered I'll do it I think
the law is on my side the loss
[Music]
stop that soup
after customers enjoy the soup which
Remy prepared Chef Skinner instructs
linguine to prepare it again let's see
what happens
[Music]
this time I'll be paying attention very
close at
they think you might be a cook but you
know what I think Linguini I think you
are a sneaky overreaching Little Rock
get the ride
[Music]
what should I do now kill it no no not
in the kitchen are you mad do you know
what would happen to us if anyone knew
we had a lot in our kitchen
those Astound our reputation is hanging
by a thread as it is take it away from
here far away kill it this pose of It Go
es
garbage boy when Chef Skinner calls
linguine garbage boy he's insulting him
this is because linguine is a dishwasher
which is a person who is responsible for
washing dishes cleaning the kitchen area
and taking out the garbage can you guess
which of these words also means garbage
rubbish trash waste
foreign
in fact all three of them
check out this example sorry you went
through the trouble I would have told
you to Chuck it I don't know if you
don't want it throw it in the rubbish
we're taking out the trash
this street is the First Street in the
city to have an underground sewer system
before that sewage and waste would just
flow right down the street
you are cooking
as you probably know questions in
English normally have the auxiliary verb
preceding the subject so do you know why
the chef said you are cooking and not
are you cooking both phrases are
actually acceptable but they have
different applications are you cooking
is a question that asks if someone is
currently cooking or planning to cook in
the near future for example if you walk
into a kitchen and you see someone
standing in front of the stove you could
ask are you cooking to make sure you
understand what they are doing your
cooking can be used like in this case to
express surprise for example if you see
someone who you didn't expect to be
cooking you could say you are cooking
in this situation we use the phrase the
gall to describe someone's excess
confidence in doing something that is
inappropriate or disrespectful we mean
that the person is acting with a
complete lack of shame or consideration
for others for example she had the gall
task for a raise after coming in late to
work every day
we also use the Expression where do you
get the gall as a rhetorical question to
express disbelief or disapproval of
someone's Behavior or actions by the way
oratorical question is one we ask
without expecting an answer in the
previous example her boss's response to
this might be where do you get the gall
task for a raise
if something is described as Monumental
it means that it is very large
significant impressive or important so
here Chef Skinner is once again
insulting linguine by basically saying
that for him to cook would be very or
significantly idiotic check out this
other example from The Simpsons to all
the male participants your Monumental
incompetence has solid and sheep in
space forever
I'll do it I think that always on my
side chef Skinner is using these
expressions hyperbolically in an
exaggerated way drawing and quartering
refers to a cruel form of executing
people from medieval times more
literally speaking to draw in this case
means to pool or drag like a horse-drawn
carriage Decor means to cut something in
four pieces
when someone or in this case the law is
on your side it means that they support
or agree with you for example if you're
playing a board game with a friend
friend and they help you win you might
say thanks for being on my side or if
you're having an argument with someone
and a third person agrees with your
point of view you might say I'm glad
you're on my side
seriously you brought you over to take
your side your dad's on your side oh no
oh no the word blathering to describe
someone who talks too much often in a
way that is annoying or not very
interesting
about customers are asking what is new
what should I tell them
let's look at the grammar here either or
is conjunction used to present a choice
between two options it is often used in
a sentence to connect two nouns verbs
adjectives or adverbs for example either
you can come to the party or you can
stay at home
the opposite of either or would be
neither nor which basically means not
either of two options for example she
neither smiled nor said hello when she
saw me be careful I've noticed many
Learners will say or this or that or nor
this nor that however this is not
correct in English
you will pay attention means to focus
your mental effort on something or
someone in order to observe listen or
learn in this case Chef Skinner means
that he will be watching linguine to see
how he prepares the soup
[Music]
instead of one okay I'll pay attention
because this part's tricky Daisy you
might be a cook but you know what I
think Linguini now despite Chef
Skinner's French accent he still uses
some connected speech like a native
speaker when a word ending in a t sound
is followed by a word ending with a Y
sound they often morph into a sound so
but you becomes but you but you know
let's listen again
you know what I think linguini
[Music]
you are a sneaky overreaching little
Rock Chef Skinner gives us some great
examples in these clips of how not to
sound polite when you speak English
if you describe someone as sneaky you
believe that person is behaving in a way
that can't be trusted and that they
don't want to be seen by others for
example Tom is so sneaky he always tries
to find a way to cheat on tests without
getting caught I need your help but in
order to help me I need you to be sneaky
we can say that someone is overreaching
if they're trying to achieve or do more
than is reasonable or achievable usually
to gain more power control or success
and then they are entitled to or capable
of for example The Athlete's
overreaching desire to win the
championship led him to burning out this
year for Valentine's Day we're gonna
have a nice quiet dinner at Ibiza last
year we um
we overreached a little I
you are a sneaky we're reaching Little
Rock as you might know rats don't
usually like to be seen they often move
around and find food without people
knowing it so if you describe someone as
a rat you mean that that person is
behaving in a dishonest or sneaky way
and is perhaps even trying to harm
others for their own benefit in the
singing it's quite funny because Remy is
literally a rat you are a lonely woman
who can make a halfway decent Brownie
and we all have our little secrets clear
right you double crossing hand holding
sneaky little rat
oh
get the Run shortly
if you trap something you catch it using
an object or strategy preventing it from
escaping in this scene linguine traps
Remy in a glass jar
and when you have a second later I want
to show you why we don't just trap
spiders under coffee mugs and leave them
there do you know what would happen to
us if you want you weird
if a business in this case a restaurant
closes down it means that it is forced
to stop operating often permanently
we're hungry Bobby open up I can't Teddy
Tommy closed this down if I serve you I
could go to jail her reputation is
hanging by a child as it is reputation
means how a person or place is viewed by
others usually based on their actions
behavior and character so we say that
someone or something has a good or bad
reputation for example the politician
has had a bad reputation ever since he
was caught lying to the public
or the restaurant has a good reputation
for serving the best pizza in town you
have a reputation for a much more
refined approach my reputation I have a
reputation
I Googled you if something is literally
hanging by a thread it means that there
is very little keeping it attached to
the hole for example he was holding on
to the Rope but he was hanging by a
thread now when describing a situation
Pain by thread implies that it is
unstable and that there is only a slim
chance of saving something
for example The Athlete's Olympic Dreams
were hanging by a thread after she
suffered a serious injury
you're hanging on
I'm hanging on
that so if someone's reputation is
hanging by a thread it means that they
are at risk of losing the respect trust
or admiration of others an expression
that sounds quite similar is to hang in
there this expression is typically used
to encourage someone to persevere or to
keep going despite difficulties or
challenges it's a way of telling someone
to hold on stay strong and keep trying
check out this fun example from Friends
I'm Ted and I just moved here a month
ago and New York really scares me
all right there you go yeah you hang in
there Teddy
you know quite often traditional methods
can seem boring uninspiring demotivating
and they just make you want to give up
but hang in there we have a course
that's really going to help you to turn
things around it's called the flute with
friends course and this has got to be
the most fun natural and convenient way
for you to take your English to the next
level in this course you will Master
connected speech so you can understand
us natives no matter how fast we speak
we will teach you the vocabulary the
news actually use every day so that
you'll be able to understand better and
even speak more confidently and finally
you also get to learn about the cultural
context so you can laugh along with
every single joke and why friends it's a
bit of an old Series right well the
reason we chose is because various
academic Studies have shown that is the
best TV series out there to learn
English
so what are you waiting for you can try
for free right now with our three-part
masterclass Center for that by clicking
up here or down description below
take it away from here far away kill it
dispose of It Go
if you dispose of something you get rid
of it usually by throwing it away or
selling it in this case Chef Skinner
wants linguine to get rid of Remy by
killing and throwing him away for
example a person might decide to dispose
of all clothes by donating them to a
charity or throwing them away in the
trash
anything left uh only the sour Quince
logs huh
dispose of it
[Music]
now linguine saves Remy and the two of
them realize that they could help each
other Remy loves cooking but since he's
a rat he isn't able to work as a chef
while Chef Skinner expects linguine to
recreate the soup but he has no cooking
skills let's watch this short scene
that was close are you okay up there
thank you
[Laughter]
how did you do that
[Music]
whoa that's strangely involuntary
one look and I knew we had the same
crazy idea Remy then controls linguine
by tugging his hair and teaching him to
cook before long they become the perfect
team
[Music]
another
that should do it
congratulations you were able to repeat
your accidental success but you will
need to know more than soup if you are
to survive in my kitchen boy Colette
will be responsible for teaching you how
we do things here
[Music]
that was close that was close it's an
idiomatic expression that we often use
to express relief after we avoid a
potentially dangerous or risky situation
for example if someone almost gets hit
by a car while crossing the street they
might say that was close to express
relief that they were not injured here's
a fun example from Brooklyn Nine-Nine
close there's a pain in your hair are
you okay up there here Linguini asked
the question you pay up there but as you
can see he emits the auxiliary verb are
you may have noticed that it's common
for native speakers to admit auxiliary
verbs and questions especially in casual
conversations let's take a look at an
example from Finding Nemo
hey what you doing it's gone
how did you do that here we have another
nice example of connected speech you
probably noticed that the D sound and
the Y sound combine to make a j sound so
what we hear is how did you do that
how did you do this
whoa that's strangely involuntary
when we say something is involuntary we
mean that it happens automatically
without us choosing or deciding to do it
for example our heartbeat is involuntary
we don't have to think about making it
happen it just happens on its own the
other day you sneezed into a napkin
that's different oh I sneeze is
involuntary
congratulations you were able to repeat
your accidental success accidental
success means achieving something good
or positive without planning or
intending to do so it's like if you're
trying to do one thing but ended up
doing something else really well by
mistake for example although she had
never intended to be a chef her famous
dessert recipe was an accidental success
that brought her Fame and Fortune and
you need to know malls and soup if you
have to survive in my kitchen boy if you
refer to an adult male or female as boy
or girl it can be insulting because it
suggests that they are childish or
inferior and therefore less deserving
respect and dignity as the words boy or
girl are not generally disrespectful it
also depends on if it is used in a
superior tone Colette will be
responsible for teaching you how we do
things here being responsible for
something it means that you're in charge
of making sure it gets done or taken
care of
before I have my bridesmaids dresses
won't get picked up my veil gets lost or
I don't have my something blue hey
hey responsible for
for example if you're responsible for
taking care of a pet it means that it's
your job to feed it give it water play
with it and make sure it stays healthy
or if you're responsible for cleaning
your room it means that it's your job to
make sure your room is neat and tidy all
right now comes the fun part you get to
test everything you learned today by
watching again without subtitles so are
you ready to see how well you'll do
let's roll it
foreign
[Music]
which of these is similar to where do
you get the gall
how dare you how come
how do you do
[Music]
Monument
I'll do it I think the Lord is on my
side Laos
what
does blathering mean
to be a coward to show weakness to talk
a lot
please
this soup
[Music]
stop that soup
he's a very lucky or very unlucky you
will make the soup again and this time
I'll be paying attention very close
attention they think you might be a cook
but you know what I think Linguini I
think you are a sneaky overreaching
little
rock
candy rush
[Music]
what should I do now kill it no no not
in the kitchen are you mad do you know
what would happen to us if anyone knew
we had a lot in our kitchen
town our reputation is hanging by a
thread as it is take it away from here
far away kill it dispose of It Go
close
there
[Music]
[Laughter]
foreign
how did you do that
[Music]
whoa that's strangely involuntary
which of these actions is usually
involuntary
coughing sneezing dancing
[Music]
one look and I knew we had the same
crazy idea
that should do it
congratulations you were able to repeat
your accidental success but you will
need to know more than soup if you are
to survive in my kitchen boy Colette
will be responsible for teaching you how
we do things here
oh yeah thanks so much again for joining
me in today's lesson I hope you enjoyed
it if you did give it a like to let
YouTube know that you want more videos
like this and if you learn Ratatouille
as much as I did then you might want to
check out our other lesson with it don't
just take my word for it it has millions
of views so let's check out a clip from
that
foreign
[Music]